[Music]
okay someone who's here in not worth it
news sounds like a good one submitted by
Hong Kong milk tea and influence it is
going to prison over a plot to steal a
URL he wanted feel like more influences
should go to prison no just because yeah
there's a lot of best going on and URLs
are the least of it
yep a lot of people who should go to
jail what do you know what do you know
what's the teeth means just the idea of
memes right joke stealing yeah
people getting famous of other people's
stuff ten ideas you should go to jail
for that piracy usually go to jail
father things I'm sure in fact you just
pointed yourself I know he's guilty how
do you steal URL that sounds like a plot
for a really crazy thriller isn't that
like go daddy's fall or something for
mixing it up we don't know how they did
it she's gonna tell us this is actually
like once you hear the whole story and
be like wow this is stupid okay I didn't
think of her stupid already not be like
even more like once you hear the details
of the extent of this [ __ ] okay so this
guy back when he was a student at Iowa
State in 2015 his name is Rossi Rossi
lothario Adams a second oh damn this you
should go to jail for that name oh [ __ ]
I mean yeah that sucks so he dreamt up
of launching this thing called state
snaps have you guys heard of it it has
over a million followers on Instagram
Wow
so this whole thing is when they collect
videos and photos of college kids just
partying getting drunk and doing dumb
[ __ ] so it's kind of like like girls
gone wild mixed with jackass who's
calling wild with jackass that sounds
wild yeah gonna have to do some research
on this they started this thing called
hashtag do it for states but the four it
spelled out fo are right so he couldn't
get that website do it for state so
instead he got do it for with the number
four state comm and so he really really
really wanted that URL with fo r and he
was able to track down the person who
owned it went to their home got his
homie to
with him well before that actually he
sent him Dan's with like gun emojis and
threatening are you serious look anyone
if this is are you threat with the emoji
to take over I'm about it with the gun
emojis the title thing that's gonna
scare anybody was this pre or post the
gun turning through a water gun takes
the edge off that's a good point so then
in the summer of 2017 that's when that's
when he went physically to the oh he's
living my dreams right now yeah he went
to his home forced him to hand over the
domain name well he got his cousin to do
all the dirty work so his cousin Sherman
he was on that drove over there and then
put a gun to his head and said like you
know you got to do this isn't this like
all this water gun a real gun and then
he gave him all these steps to try to
transfer over the URL but that's when
the the victim was able to get the gun
out of the Quahog yeah and then so he
was able to call the police that's some
brave ass [ __ ] he actually shot him so
it said he wrangled a gun out and then
[ __ ] shot so he got the gun but
during the struggle he was shot in the
leg and then the victim shot the cousin
multiple times in the chest but he
actually survived closed is a water gun
yeah so then um luckily he survived and
he was sentenced to 20 years in prison
and now the original guy that wanted all
this [ __ ] he is being found guilty of
conspiracy to interfere with commerce by
force threats and violence
Jerris cousin the good thing is now we
can start to it for State Penn calm now
he's gonna start a new Instagram of
inmates gone wild yeah this is Roxy the
guy that wanted the URL badly wonder
what school he went to Iowa State
College dreams ruined well that was back
in 2015 so and then his cousin Sherman
who did all the pretty quick when you
see Sherman you see he's an OG yeah he
looks like the guy that does all
I did not picture these guys at all
shemin's you that dog that a name like
Sherman's like only one of two things it
was the first life I know I pictured the
nerd yeah shame because it was like
who's like putting the DNS servers now
Go Daddy like transfer the domain to me
bro like I thought it was a nerd I
thought these are like nerdy like white
kids doing Instagram [ __ ] looks like an
old guy that doesn't even know what a
URL is you know yeah so he got like a
piece of paper girl give me oh yeah do
this [ __ ] what if I get all that yeah
that's never crossed your guys minds
when you want a URL and then some
someone [ __ ] Park it would you show
up like this so excited I forgot to tell
you guys how Sherman showed up so he
showed up carrying a cell phone is
stolen gun a Taser wearing a hat
pantyhose on his head and dark
sunglasses on it give me all your URLs
stand at robbery just like once you know
everything that happened it just sounds
funny because he I could picture him
like stumbling as [ __ ] cuz he can't see
right and that's how he got the gun
taken out of his hand sounds like a plan
for a good movie
I know sunglasses over pantyhose huh on
home would be ridiculous shit's not
falling off maybe I was not picturing
these guys at all you pictured like frat
boys yeah well not even frat boy like
these geeky like nerdy cats like that
like our super entitled mommy and daddy
like gave them everything they wanted
but not these guys especially with the
second
you know I pictured like something yeah
rich frat boy boat choose pink shorts
yeah yeah exactly
maybe red hair somewhere in there we got
prison Forest Whitaker over here he kind
of looks like old ashy Larry
Darnell daughter I know where all this
yeah Dan that sucks
I always wanted to do that though
because someone parked some sites that
we that we wanted that are that should
be rightfully ours but we don't have to
domain for I always wondered who owned
that who was the person that parked it
yeah I [ __ ] hate it cuz it's like big
companies that just buy it and then you
go to that site and it's advertising I'm
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah so they
just get them just to sell them yeah
there's a lot of people they just go
like just random like keywords like sumo
dot-com or like baseball calm
just buy all of it up then they know one
day a big company come knocking and
paying well Sherman is gonna come
knocking yeah
more Sherman big company Sherman I wish
I could go back in time is that [ __ ]
Lululemon McDonald's McDonald's calm can
you imagine how rich you would be if you
parked all of that [ __ ] like when it
first came out was crazy you you could
have done that yeah McDonald's was
before the internet for sure and so
we'll all of we yeah we didn't know how
to do it yeah give me McDonald's I don't
even know you could buy a URL what you
think it's just happened yeah just
granted to you when I was like 13 I was
like build a website cuz you know when
you make those free websites like
remember angel fire or whatever yeah and
then you just get your own link so I
thought I thought I didn't know you
could change it or like people changed
it when they built their own website I
don't know I just made up my own rules I
didn't even think I could have a website
I thought it was just for big companies
it really looked to fall by in the K I
know right it's just like some of these
things it's like right there but you
just never know and if we were there to
park all those names off we would have
been so [ __ ] rich well if I only had
a time machine that's what you do with
it huh was company get it was a porn
site kind of it's like soft porn because
it's girls gone wild meets jackass yeah
titties people crashing I think it's
girls gone wild meet Justin right what
what does it do exactly so it's like
girls got one plus jackass so it's like
it gets all that it collects all these
things and it puts it on one eye like
[ __ ] Jerry how they could like they have
all these different memes that they'll
get from the internet
don't yeah they stole yep stolen ass so
this place would do they would just get
all these college videos and photos and
then post them up on their page it has
1.5 million on Instagram do any more you
in jail [ __ ] damn that sucks
what an idiot dude he's only 26 and I'm
sure he could have bought it off dude
well she was also fine to like the
number
it's shorter but he had to get the F Oh
our man I was saying like here at the
story you're gonna realize how stupid
that is stupid yeah what we gonna say
don't remember look up that site later
I was thinking oh thing about the
content what if I'm still going I was
gonna show you guys some rollin yeah you
guys can find out your own yes this
person I'm sure was gonna look it up cuz
it's girls gone wild what happened to
that guy
that's a suit I think for underage I
call you at his place in Mexico twice
really real story I'm gonna yeah actual
real story I don't believe it okay I
don't know how to tell you it's a real
story let me start again
real story Mexico 2012 Mexico 2013 part
of Arthur he lives out there in a
mansion and he brings as you would
imagine bus filled with girls out to his
place this during his peak time was this
after after that's true cuz it was like
early 2000s that they were playing girls
gone wrong a lot on TV you know I was
one of the lucky few guys along with the
people who knew him that got to go on
the bus we got out there he's got jet
skis horses sushi masseuse people guy
walking around rolling joints it was the
whole day get back on the bus to go back
to the rest of Mexico well yeah he's
hiding out in Mexico his mansion like
the people who run the spring-break
companies are friends with them so
they're like oh you know like we gotta
go around and get girls to ask if you
want to go which is funny cuz you're
like what's up girls you want to go
party at a Joe Francis house who the
girls gone wild guy and a lot of girls
would be like [ __ ] now also think were
lying
we weren't lying and the girls have got
the go got on the bus then you later go
back to their friends tell them about
this [ __ ] wild time man and the
friends have pissed but that's the story
I tell you everyone so of course you
want to get in this bus to drive into
the middle of poyo out there and you
know I won't even believe girls were
said yes well that's that is how he made
his money
I can't believe girls said yes should
have been the title
[ __ ] is going on
that's why she shot to show me your
titties of course there's a mansion [ __ ]
yeah what are these girls exist
I've never do you follow grill [ __ ]
[ __ ] Whisperer on Instagram yeah that's
the new guy I thought you guys Instagram
oh you either dude that put stickers on
the girls asses right on their tits
Aziz hurry I'm got shut down why my
Instagram I mean he was showing a lot of
[ __ ]
yeah but they just completely took it
away from theirs completely shut it down
it was he violating stuff that's not
fair because there's all this puppy
animal abuse they even verify them too
and then they shut them down the insult
verify hey buddy you got it yourself a
nice checkmark and then I'm like way to
like let's just take it easy
wait is that hard
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]